the impeachment hearings picked up again
today and man it was honestly pretty
damn boring yeah it was just for
constitutional law experts discussing
the intricacies of impeachment precedent
and process this is a clip this is
actually one of the more tense moments
take a look the framers didn't disagree
with Mason's view that bribery was too
narrow what they disagreed with was when
he suggested maladministration to add to
the standard because he wanted it to be
broader yeah
pretty dry yeah so as you can guess not
many people watched it in fact it was so
boring here are some of the programs
that they showed on other networks they
easily beat the hearings in the ratings
easily beat them these shows destroyed
the hearings in the ratings HGTV beat
them with their latest popular series
paint drying in real time where the
channel got better ratings with a
countdown of 2019 s best fogs ESPN beat
them with infield dirt raking highlights
yeah so did espn2 with stairlift races
[Applause]
Animal Planet's it better with dog
dentistry marathon finally TLC got
better ratings in the impeachment with
her new show people trying to explain
their dreams
I was the pencil but not like a
normal-size pencil like maybe 15 or 20
percent larger and when I was moving I
was drawing a picture this girl Colleen
I went to camp with
[Applause]